[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue merci de nous resté fidèle jusqu'au
dernier rendez vous de la semaine mais
rassurez vous on reviendra la semaine
prochaine quand même ce soir pour
débattre des sujets brûlants de
l'actualité maxime des gayets bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes conseiller régional
ile de france mais pas seulement puisque
vous présidez le groupe socialiste et
écologiste vous êtes donc le patron de
l'opposition à valérie pécresse peut
dire ça comme ça on peut dire ça comme
ça
si l'auteur de la grande des possessions
pour une éthique numérique européenne
c'est un ouvrage qui a été publiée par
la fondation jean jaurès donc dont vous
êtes l'un des experts bonsoir jean
christophe buisson soit vous êtes
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro magazine qui publie ce week-end
en couverture sa sélection annuelle est
toujours très attendue des chambres
d'hôtes on y reviendra tout à l'heure
mais vous êtes aussi un passionné
d'histoire vous animez d'ailleurs une
émission sur la chaîne histoire et vous
avez collaboré un magnifique album dont
vous avez écrit plutôt les textes ou
tout autre domaine consacrée aux lieux
des lieux l'esprit des lieux c'est ça
c'est à dire les lieux principaux où est
allé napoléon dont nous commémorons dans
quelques jours la sont le centenaire de
la mort mais j'ajoute le bicentenaire
merci c'est pour voir si vous suiviez
j'ajoute que l'esprit des lieux a été
publié aux éditions michel lafon
c'est un sondage qui est paru cette
semaine un sondage harris interactive
pour nos confrères de challenges à un an
presque jour pour jour
si je me trompe pas de l'élection
présidentielle mais bien il se confirme
que la gauche n'est pas en très bon état
regarder ce que sont ces simulations de
vote du premier tour alors bien sûr on
est à un an ça n'est qu'une photographie
mais c'est quand même intéressant
l'hypothèse qui est retenu là c'est
celle où xavier bertrand et le candidat
de des républicains ou en tout cas de la
droite classique on va dire mais ça
changerait pas pour la gauche les scores
seraient les mêmes s'ils valérie
pécresse était candidate
le total de la gauche ça fait 26 %
yannick jadot
l'écologiste dont on disait qu'il avait
plutôt le vent en poupe souvenez-vous de
ses succès aux municipales fait 6%
anne hidalgo fait 6% c'est-à-dire le
même score que benoît hamon en 2017 jean
luc mélenchon et à 11% d'intentions de
vote
alors qu'il tentait les 20 % en 2017
bref ça va pas fort
maxime des gayets je le disais vous êtes
un des hommes qui comptent au parti
socialiste vous êtes proche d'olivier
forts sont secrètes son patron son
secrétaire-général c'est ça le type soc
qu'international merci je savais que
j'étais en train de me tromper
bon alors qu'est ce qui se passe la ccc
et c'est foutu pour votre camp je ne
pense pas ce qui se passe d'abord c'est
con à un an d'une élection donc vous le
savez certainement
d'ailleurs beaucoup de familles
politiques ont pu le connaître de
mémoire je crois que les deux derniers
présidents de la république étaient à
moins de 5% un an d'une élection très de
l'élection présidentielle donc il faut
toujours également françois hollande
emmanuel macron exactement donc faut
toujours pouvoir se méfier des sondages
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement ces photographies
d'opinion elles veulent dire elle veut
dire aussi des choses et qu'il faut en
tirer des enseignements
le premier enseignement qu'on peut tirer
c'est d'abord le fait que eh bien tout
est construit autour du débat entre jean
marie le pen et emmanuel macron mari de
marine le pen patron emmanuel macron
quand je dis tout est construit ce n'est
pas seulement
ce que font les sondeurs c'est d'abord
le débat politique et la façon dont les
uns et les autres nourrissent cette
confrontation qui est attendu mais qui à
mon avis l'as déjà beaucoup beaucoup des
français la deuxième chose c'est que
quand vous dites que la gauche va mal
elle fait 25% elle fait plus cumuler 26%
d'ailleurs cumuler sur ce sondage est
donc le vrai sujet c'est que et bien
c'est finalement la division qui est un
élément de démobilisation
quand vous voyez ce qui s'est passé aux
élections municipales vous savez que le
peuple de gauche il existe on a eu des
victoires importantes dans de nombreuses
villes à montpellier notamment et dans
de grand nombre de villes en france et
d'ailleurs en ile de france
et puis même quand vous voyez d'ailleurs
les prochaines élections régionales ou
départementales vous apercevez que par
exemple en ile de france
la gauche elle n'est pas à 25% elle est
déjà 36 37 % et qu'elle peut jouer la
gagne donc le peuple de gauche existe
aujourd'hui n'arrive pas à se projeter
dans l'élection présidentielle et moi
mon sentiment c'est qu'il faut donc
pouvoir travailler l'offre est en
capacité de pouvoir rassembler autour
d'un projet autour d'une personnalité
vous l'avez peut-être vu
et entendu il ya quelques jours à peine
olivier faur yannick jadot ont pris des
initiatives pour essayer de construire
ce rassemblement j'ajoute que vous
faisiez le total des voix de gauche dans
ce qui n'est qu'un sondage mais
qu'effectivement de 26% alors ensuite ça
des pensions mais marine le pen à droite
ou pas mais si on additionne les voix au
premier tour de xavier bertrand de
marine le pen et de nicolas dupont
aignan on est à 46 ce qui montre un
petit peu où est le le lait la moyenne
de l'hadopi aux politiques de notre pays
jean christophe buisson s'est pas perdue
pour la gauche
je pense que les gauches sont devenus
irréconciliables en grande partie à
cause de macron qui a réussi quand même
essayer aussi d'ailleurs en partie
valable pour la droite ce que je vais
dire qui a vraiment fait exploser ce
clivage droite gauche dont on ne cesse
de répéter que finalement il continue à
construire peu ou prou la société
française et s'est pas totalement vrai
parce que je pense que macron lui ne
raisonne plus en droit de gauche
c'est-à-dire que quand lundi fait cette
interview au figaro il fait du
sécuritaire ont dû regarder il est en
train de virer à droite
moi je crois pas qu'ils sont en train de
virer à droite il fait ce que faisait à
chevènement ou j'ose pas en disant que
la sécurité c'est un sujet qui est une
île rodkin au niveau jeu qui concerne
plutôt des classes populaires et classes
moyennes qui souffre de sa est temps que
la gauche tombera dans le piège de dire
que la sécurité c'est forcément de
droite
macron sera à 25 ou 30% ce que je viens
par là c'est que si la gauche
aujourd'hui c'est toujours les vieux
réflexes d'une gauche un peu morale
c'est la comptes critique la droite
c'est d'un point de vue moral sécurité
et cetera sans comprendre qu'il ya des
sujets maintenant qui vraiment dépasse
le clivage que macro est le seul à avoir
fait je pense que la gauche ne
ressurgira pas ni eux ni derrière une
personnalité aussi charismatique soit
elle ni derrière un programme parce que
elle est irréconciliable entre une
partie qui est devenu totalement
radicalise et notamment la france
insoumise notamment parti communiste et
notamment chez certains verts et une
partie qui est la gauche traditionnelle
réformiste social démocrate qui à 80% en
partie chez macron et qui n'en est pas
revenu d'avant les strauss kahniens qui
ne revienne pas est ce qu'il en reste ce
sont des gens comme olivier faure comme
anne hidalgo
mais qui peine à exister
et parce que deux temps en temps quand
même ce discours anti droite morale
ils ont envie de l'entretenir quand anne
hidalgo s'énerve dès qu'on la critique
en disant c'est un coup de l'extrême
droite je pense pas que c'est comme ça
qu'elle va fédérer la gauche qui pense
la baule à gauche la dent dans le film
nine ce week-end on publie un débat
auquel participent les deux finales
stade juste de la fondation jean jaurès
qui est absolument passionnant dans son
analyse et dans son aveu d'échec
justement de cette posture lui il en est
même à dire je sais pas si vous portez
gsid que parti comme c'est marine le pen
oui c'est tout à fait tout à fait
possible qu'elle entre à l'elysée si on
ne trie pas quelque chose et quand vous
dites que que la gauche manque soit de
programmes ces deux personnalités je
crois que c'est pas la personnalité
parce que des gens comme encore une fois
anne hidalgo olivier faure au sautoir
hidalgo a fait ses preuves
même si on n'est pas laisser revenir la
critique et donc c'est pas les
personnalités qui manque c'est vraiment
c'est quoi le projet l'analyse la
société aujourd'hui de la gauche et le
projet d'une gauche qui ne soit pas
tenté par cette encore une fois cette
traditionnelle critique morale de la
grotte
d'abord je cancon vous indiquer que
emmanuel macron à troubler le jeu et les
clivages politiques je ne peux qu'être
d'accord avec vous au premier point le
deuxième point c'est que je crois que là
aussi la société va se rappeler à la
politique c'est à dire que moi mon
sentiment aujourd'hui c'est que le
clivage gauche droite est
particulièrement pertinent sur de grands
sujets notamment dans l'évolution de
notre économie dans les ravages qui sont
faits aujourd'hui par la précarisation
des salariés en raison des nouveaux
modèles économiques et donc moi je crois
que
on aura une présidentielle qui serait
une présidentielle qui sera inscrite
dans j'espère l'après crise du coc vide
et pour moi il y aura des visions deux
sociétés est la question que vous posez
juste c'est quelle est la raison d'être
finalement de la gauche est aujourd'hui
il faut être en capacité pourra répondre
à des enjeux qui sont des enjeux
contemporains
donc pour moi le sujet aujourd'hui il
est que la gauche a un rôle à jouer dans
l'histoire de notre pays que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans le quotidien des
gens vous me dites la gauche aujourd'hui
n'existe pas dans le débat public moi je
vous le dis aujourd'hui la gauche elle
existe dans les préoccupations des gens
et elle est en capacité de avec avant
capacité de pouvoir de pouvoir leur
répondre il faut pour le coup qu'elle
soit audible et qu'elle est soit en
dynamique et quads sont en capacité de
se fédérer après consignes on est des
non résidents et après quand vous
indiquez mais bon on peut
moi j'essaie justement de pousser à ce
que le débat politique évoluée sera et
se rapproche des préoccupations des gens
j'aimerais sortir des rengaines et en
l'occurrence quand vous m'expliquer que
la gauche un prêt avec la sécurité ça
c'était enfin ça fait 20 ans qu'on nous
dise à 20 ans que la gauche a démontré
qu'elle avait été capable de prendre en
charge les problématiques de sécurité
qu'elle avait été capable d'ailleurs de
comptes de deux poutres de mieux les
prendre en charge que la droite parce
que nous on a créé des postes quand la
droite et est incapable de le faire
c'est un sujet récurent it ayant estimé
c revient pour dire mais c'est pas grave
mon secteur de l'interview de l' indice
mais c'est ça mais c'est pas vrai si
mais non mais vous confondez ça me
permettait la question de la sécurité
qui est la première des libertés
commandé pour nos concitoyens et les
discours sécuritaires qui vise à créer
mais c'est ça la difficulté c'est que
vous le savez lire dans dans le discours
d' emmanuel macron ya quoi dans le
figaro
il ya des mesures nouvelles non il ya il
ya des chiffres réels non plus valérie
rabault a montré que et bien les
et les nouveaux postes qui étaient
annoncés étaient en fait totalement
contradictoire et tes propres
projections de ce gouvernement
il ya juste à volonté je te raconte tout
ce que c'est la patronne du groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale
exactement et qui connaît bien les
chiffres et qui ont une occurrence a
fait une démonstration qui était assez
clair et donc si vous voulez le quand
vous parlez de sécurité vous parler de
la prise en charge de la problématique
sécuritaire par des acteurs politiques
vous savez les socialistes dirigent des
villes depuis de nombreuses années et
d'ailleurs ils ont été confirmés aux
dernières élections municipales et les
enjeux de sécurité quand vous touchez à
la proximité il faut avoir des réponses
immédiates et jusqu'à preuve du
contraire les français leur font
confiance là dessus alors après on
pourrait quand même voix et dire que par
exemple est ce que une garde des sceaux
comme christiane taubira incarner aux
yeux des français la sécurité pourrait
en débattre dit léon va pas remonter
trop loin je vous donne le point de vue
de nos internautes alors on vous pose la
question sur twitter ce n'est pas un
sondage ce sont ceux qui nous font le
plaisir de suivre l'émission qui
s'exprime la gauche at-elle déjà perdu
la présidentielle dès 2022 c'est oui à
85% moment davantage c'est que ça peut
que s'améliorer
quelques commentaires de freddy sur
twitter quand leur seul programme
consiste à ne rien proposer
et seulement s'indigner sur tout et
n'importe quoi en insultant ceux qui ne
sont pas d'accord d'être d'extrême
droite
oui ils ont déjà perdu si la gauche
disparaît entre guillemets nous dit
nicole 0,6 sur lefigaro.fr c'est encore
macron qui va en profiter
une autre sur lefigaro.fr rien n'est
plié à un an des présidentielles il ne
faudrait pas réduire l'éventail du
nombre de candidats éventuels
et puis
cette réaction d'alfred sur youtube pas
sûr que la gauche ait déjà perdu face à
marine le pen
n'importe qui sera élue elle ne sert
qu'à ça elle c'est marine le pen fait
réélire d'office le candidat face à elle
jean christophe buisson cité anne
hidalgo
maxime des grilles est ce que vous êtes
quand même pas un peu surpris et pas
forcément en bien de son niveau dans les
sondages elle est critiquée certes mais
c'est une vraie femme de gauche elle est
maire de la capitale a été réélu held a
donné beaucoup de gages à l'écologie
franchement elle était un pont au-dessus
de nicolas dupont aignan cessé il ya un
truc qui coince la non non je ne pense
pas qu'ils aient un truc qui coince
enfin jeu on voit bien les sondages je
vais pas les évidemment masquer des
chiffres qui sont évidemment plus tôt
déceptif mais si voulez moi je ne pense
pas parce que vous comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même l'ensemble des candidats de
gauche à peu près les mêmes les mêmes
scores mise à part où jean-luc mélenchon
- c'est la même chose pour yannick jadot
donc moi je pense que anne hidalgo
al'avantage comme vous l'avez dit
d'avoir évidemment et bien la carrure
d'une grande responsable grande femme
d'état que deuxièmement elle est au
point d' équilibre aussi de ce que peut
être cette nouvelle gauche contemporaine
par ses engagements écologiques par son
volontarisme et donc moi je pense
qu'elle est bien positionné il ya deux
sujets kiné qui en réalité sont des
obstacles ou des difficultés aujourd'hui
à sa progression dans l'opinion publique
le premier on l'a évoqué c'est la
capacité même à pouvoir se projeter en
raison des divisions de la gauche je
pense qu'il faut être en capacité de
montrer aussi notre envie de pouvoir de
pouvoir rassembler et puis un deuxième
sujet qui la concernent pas parce
qu'elle est dans l'action en étant maire
de paris mais c'est aussi et pour le
coup vous voyez je suis capable
d'entendre ce que ce que vous indiquez
la capacité de la gauche à pouvoir
proposer des choses ce qu'on fait parce
que nous avons engagé nous des chantiers
sur les questions de santé sur les
questions du travail
on propose aujourd'hui est bien de
réduire par exemple
et bien l'écart entre de 1 à 20 dans les
salaires on propose des mesures assez
forte en matière de santé pour s'assurer
que le droit et l'accès aux soins soit
une réalité dans notre pays et donc je
pense qu'il ya un vrai travail aussi
programmatique de projets engagés et
donc je pense qu'il est encore un peu
tôt pour anne hidalgo dans un moment où
reconnaissons reconnaissez le reconnaît
son le jeu y arriver les français
arrivent venu à dire ce que la forme et
que je vais l'avoir mais par contre
souffre quand même de la crise pandémie
qui ont du mal à se projeter dans un
débat présentiel et là je vous d'accord
avec vous c'est de patienter pas tant
que ça je pense que les régionales vont
être un test pour la gauche puisque
c'est de ça dont il s'agit et notamment
en terme de sa capacité effectivement à
se réunir et ce qui va se passer
notamment dans dans les hauts de france
avec karima delli qui fait une liste un
peu arc en ciel à la jospin ou la russie
du parti communiste jusque jusqu'au ps
et peut-être même les radicaux de gauche
ou ce qu'il en reste comme en normandie
d'ailleurs voilà à faire ça alors que le
grand est exactement la verse la bouche
et donc c'est très symptomatique de
effectivement du problème qu'à la gauche
aujourd'hui c'est si on arrive à s'unir
et quand même là les souvenirs et ont
fait jeu égal à peine avec eux et leur
assemblée nationale et macro mais encore
une fois je reviens c'est mal c'est ma
marotte c'est que si leur asthme au
national et macron sont à 25 26 % c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas soit de droite et de
gauche sont les deux et la boue tête de
noeud guillaume tout à l'heure et juste
je pense que dans le programme de marine
le pen ya des choses qui ne sont plus
tôt de deux gauches comme on dit la
sécurité droite le social et de gauche
qui est d'accord avec mylène une des
jurées formule mais c'est souvent ce
qu'on retient
et comme elle un programme qui est assez
social je pense que les gens de gauche
qui restent chez marine le pen
et comme en plus le sécuritaire et pas
forcément de droite il y reste ils sont
bien et tant qu'il n'y a pas encore une
fois cette explosion de c2c schéma là à
gauche comme à droite dans la gauche
traditionnelle droite traditionnelle je
pense qu'on restera avec ces deux
candidats au dessus du lot et donc on va
voir comment karima delli si par exemple
elles l'emportent comment elle gère
cette situation avec une une gauche
rassemblée mais rassemblée sur quels
thèmes sur quelles valeurs en campagne
très bien on va battre la droite on va
battre xavier bertrand et ça fait un an
qu'on dit yann moix pour l'expérience et
par parenthèse mais après entre les
insoumis et là et la gauche responsable
social démocrate
moi j'attends de voir et selon ce qui
sortira de là le peuple de gauche se
dire ah oui parce qu'ici c'est la même
salade pour la présidentielle autant
qu'ils aient un candidat du ps un
candidat écologiste un candidat
françaises soumises et rendrait aspire
plutôt l'électorat de gauche aspirent à
l'unité deuxièmement nous on travaille
objectivement et
younès je me dis aujourd'hui sur des
cons là est la question c'est quelle va
être l'enjeu de l'élection
présidentielle moi je vous dis mélange
d'expérience elle va être éminemment
sociale et écologique mais social
l'écolo sécurité et vous vous verrez et
et jeu et moi je mets jeu mais un petit
billet sur le fait qu'il n'y aura pas de
second tour entre emmanuel macron et
marine le pen je n'y crois pas et
d'ailleurs l'histoire en tout cas c'est
je ne parle de man vous donc avec
beaucoup d'humilité mais enfin
l'histoire politique nous enseigne que
ces derniers aux dernières élections et
bien sait jamais ce qui était souhaité
ou attendu qui est arrivé donc voilà
d'accord et ses premiers on en reparlera
pour prolonger ce que vous disiez gens
que j'ai quand même retrait à l'usure de
petits beewi jeu petit 74
c'est son pseudonyme sur le figaro.fr ce
qui me choque c'est le rapprochement
entre l'extrême gauche du pc ou de la
france insoumise avec la gauche
et puis cette réaction de weir hôpital
déjà être contre le nucléaire c'est
vouloir délibérément perdre la
présidentielle et ben écoute on verra
c'est certainement un sujet dont on va
reparler à moins 2
vivre aux kerguelen sans liaison
internet vous ne pouvez pas ignorer que
le spationaute thomas pesquet s'est
envolé ce matin depuis cap canaveral
dans l'espace où il va rester six mois
c'est une grande fierté française on ne
parle que de ça il nous fait rêver
il nous emmène dans les étoiles vous
trouvez ça sympathique maxime d'égailler
ou est ce qu'on n'en fait pas un petit
peu trop on a peut-être mauvais esprits
ici j'en parlais juste avant l'émission
j'ai un fils de quatre ans et demi je ne
pense pas qu'ils considèrent qu'on en
parle trop parce qu'il était fasciné
avec ses yeux d'enfant tout à l'heure en
voyant le décollage de space x
donc je vois là comme je pense d'abord
que ça fait du bien
en réalité effectivement il ya un
battage médiatique important autour
finalement d'un décollage qui peut
apparaître un peu quelconque parce que
ça doit être le quatrième ou de
cinquième de cette fusée donc on peut se
dire pourquoi est ce que donne un coup
les français verse dans cet intérêt moi
je pense que si on regarde pas ce que ça
signifie c'est peut-être un peu trop si
on veut regarder un peu plus loin on
peut se dire que à travers
ce
à travers ce décollage il ya beaucoup de
choses aussi qui s'exprime 1 la volonté
de l'humanité de continuer à se dépasser
dans un moment où on voit aussi que on
est capable de dévorer la planète
et puis pour tout vous dire moi je
trouve que la conquête spatiale en
général c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est qui est une cause qui rassemble
normalement des pays et en l'occurrence
et envoie sur cette opération il ya des
européens des français des américains
des japonais et écoutez moi quand on
voit qu'on est capable de pouvoir se
fédérer sur des grands projets comme
cela ça fait plaisir et on se dit qu'on
pourrait peut-être le faire sur d'autres
grands projets je pense évidemment à la
question des vaccins où il ya des
collaborations et qui pourrait être un
peu plus importante où la question du
dérèglement climatique donc si c'est une
ode à la capacité et bien d'intérêts
nationaux continentaux à pouvoir s'unir
je pense et bien que c'est on n'en fait
pas trop sur ce type d'événement
après on peut aussi dire que comme le
fait etienne de montety ce matin dans
son éditorial du figaro que ben parce
qu'elle est français c'est formidable
mais que voilà il décolle d'une fusée
américaine
je pensais au vaccin parce que vous
disiez les vaccins ensemble oui sauf que
malheureusement n'y a pas de français
mais bon c'est comme ça
jean-christophe puissance que vous êtes
aussi enthousiaste comme maxime tanguay
est ce que vous avez des tripes toile
dans les yeux pas du tout juste pour
répondre d'abord des réglementations
climatique moi je veux bien mais
justement il ya une partie de la gauche
la gauche que vous voulez rassembler par
ailleurs qui hurlent en disant on
utilise combien de kérosène sur quoi
pour envoyer dans l'espace c'est pas
très bon pour la planète quand même ce
genre d'opération fin c'est une
c'est une petite boutade non moi je
alors ses personnels moi je suis pas
facile enfin je suis fasciné par
l'espace je suis fasciné par ça je
fasciné par la rareté que cela que cela
indiquait il ya encore 20 ans 30 ans
jolie une sorte de banalisation c'est
une course à l'espace qui devient espèce
de nouveau marché international une
nouvelle de course qui d'ailleurs est
typiquement du typique du monde
ultralibéral dénoncé parfois parfois à
gauche c'est l'échec de non seulement de
la france mais de l'europe cette affaire
parce que on a des projets qui s'appelle
ariane qui aurait dû aboutir est ce
qu'un français partent comme ça dans
l'espace et ses landes mais c'est une
start-up n'existait pas il ya dix ans
qui envoie thomas pesquet dans l'espace
donc c'est quand même
faut quand même regarder avec un peu
effectivement d'humilité mois il se
trouve que pour moi l'espace c'est le
mystère et le mystère j'aime bien que ça
reste un mystère c'est à dire que à
force d'envoyer du monde dans ce mystère
on est en train de l'élucider et les
lucides et pas tant que ça parce que
quand thomas pesquet garçon fort
sympathique au demeurant fait que trois
mille fois le tour de la terre qui ce
qu'il envoie elle envoie des photos de
la terre
donc l'on voit pas dans l'espace pour
nous montrer la terre ça me paraît tout
à fait paradoxale ce qui prouve bien que
au fond ce qui nous intéresse et
occupons nous des problèmes de la terre
et l'espace
laissons-le un petit peu avec son
mystère le mystère de l'homme de la
naissance de l'homme
le mystère de
religieux aussi moi je vois c'est pour
ça que je ne suis pas je suis pas
fasciné pour moi l'espace c'est la
science fiction c'est la littérature
c'est dans le cinéma formidable on fait
des histoires on invente tout ce qu'on
veut dans l'espace avec le cinéma et
elle est allée voir vraiment ce qui s'y
passe ou ça tu as tu le rêve qu'on a un
enfant dix ans on pourra jamais c'est
inaccessible si ça devient accessible
c'est plus un rêve et je rejoins la
maire de poitiers sur ce que vous avez
compris comment la mère de poitiers
écologistes vous rappellera qu'elle est
le s'ériger contre le fait que
l'aviation elle parlait pas de l'être
face en l'occurrence un média l'aviation
puisse être l'objet de rêve pour les
enfants et je m'étais permis d'anticiper
en disant que c'était un rêve d'enfant
c'est pour ça que je parlais de mon gel
voorhees puisque j'avais compris que ça
allait arriver après écoutez vous êtes
ligue 2 buvez clip de vos passions vous
avez le droit de ne pas vous intéresse
la sae personnes vous l'imposé la presse
par contre c'est que ça nous fasse une
part oui mais par contre je sens du mot
tout à ce qu'on se foute une par contre
il ya des arguments qui et qui
quelquefois si vous permettez son avis
mais mériterait de ne pas être sorti
parce que quand vous m'expliquer que
thomas pesquet est parti faire des
photos des nouveaux jeux à l'occasion il
fait les informations qui nous transmet
normal ces deux photos de la loi alors
que vous le savez mais alors que vous
avez bien ces démissions qui permettent
de faire et bien un grand nombre
d'expériences qui sont des expériences
précieuses y compris pour pour le
quotidien quelques fois j'ai dire moi
moi j'ai en tête des débats qu'on avait
à l'époque avec des gens qui pouvaient
quelquefois écrire dans le figaro il ya
que 2 janvier criant mais qui expliquait
que c'était normal de financer
lourdement par exemple l'industrie de
l'armement parce que derrière c'était
aussi des technologies nouvelles qui
pouvait s'appliquer dans le quotidien
si vous permettez je préfère tant qu'à
faire ce que qu'on finance aujourd'hui
des projets spatiaux pour arriver à
avoir des avancées technologiques ça ne
sert à rien et je ne vous ai jamais dit
ça je dis qu'il ya une starisation une
auto starisation avec cette affaire il
sait très bien que s'il explique ce que
vous êtes en train de dire personne ne
va rien comprendre parce que personne ne
comprend rien aux expériences qui sont
faites là ou alors il fait quoi ils
envoient des photos de la terre un peu
bisounours pour nous regarder comme je
vois depuis l'espace combien la terrible
est belle ce qui me gêne c'est là ce qui
était beau il ya 20 ans 30 ans avec
avec jean chrétien ou claudie où son
mari claudie haigneré ou jean-claude
ignorer je crois c'était il nous
envoyait pas sur les réseaux sociaux à
la seconde près afin pas la seconde 13
tout le temps que ça arrive
des images c'était quand il revenait on
était comme ça en disant mais qu'est ce
que vous avez vu qu est ce que vous avez
ressenti de là il nous dit son
expérience et son expérience pour leur
envoyer des photos de la terre c'est
tout le reste qui fait kiffer 99 % de
son temps par définition il nous en
parle pas parce qu'on n'y comprendraient
rien et moi c'est cette rareté moi je
vais très bien si je suis sur le site
dans le si dans l'espace on trouve la
solution pour soigner la coville je vais
pas m'en plaindre mais ce que la
starisation le côté visualisation vous
ne gêne un petit j'entendais voyez il ya
un programme qui est lancé pour recruter
de nouveaux
l'astronaute spationaute et d'autres
cosmonautes strictement et et vous voyez
que aujourd'hui il ya un engouement je
suis pragmatique là il
je vous disais c'est un événement comme
dit un peu banal quand on voit le nombre
de lancements qu'ils sont fainéants dans
une année si on a la possibilité là et
moi je crois que positif de pouvoir et
bien fédérer alors j'ai vu que le
gouvernement pour le coup on faisait des
tonnes parce qu'ils ont c'est que c'est
des événements qui permettent de ne pas
parler de 2,2 prom de difficultés mais
en l'occurrence moi je trouve ça plus
objectivement plutôt positif
et comme je le disais il faut aussi
saluer la collaboration vous disiez que
j'espère que vous vous indiqué tout à
l'heure que il finalement il n'y avait
qu'un français que c'était une que
c'était un appareil américain
il ya quand même beaucoup de
collaborations qui sont faites
aujourd'hui c'est c'est plutôt positif
et moi je veux plutôt voir ses
collaborations qu'une place qui serait
une place plus marginale de la france
qui par ailleurs part il ya eu quelques
il ya eu quelques d'air article
là-dessus qui a participé par une série
de reprises le court où avec un rien sur
un équipage international sa part de
france que que de floride mais nos
internautes considèrent que non on n'en
fait pas trop au sujet de thomas pesquet
60 2 % sont en tout cas de cet avis et
par mois dans la majorité
je crois que c'est la première fois
vous savez qu'ici il n'ya que des
majorités d'idées donc elles peuvent
changer au gré des sujets christophe sur
twitter nous dit on en fait trop sur lui
et pas assez sur ce qu'ils vont faire
comme expérience scientifique tandis
qu'evelyne considère que ces voyages
coûte un pognon de dengue expression
bien connue désormais et leur utilité
n'est pas franchement claire
alors pour tout vous dire chers
internautes on avait hésité à traiter
aussi cet aspect là mais on a considéré
qu'on n'était pas si vous tille et
techniquement pour le faire c'est à dire
est ce que ces expériences sont vraiment
indispensables parce que depuis le temps
qu'ils aient 16 tourne autour de la
terre peut-être que on a eu le temps de
faire toutes les expériences voulu et
que c'est surtout de la communication
mais encore une fois ça c'est un autre
thème si vous avez des idées là-dessus
vous nous en parlerait tata sur youtube
pour une fois qu'il ya un visage
français dans ses projets où on ne voit
que des américains
il faut en être fier nicole 06 oui c'est
bien mais enfin c'est trop c'est trop
les départs vers les ss et sans arrêt
donc ça n'a pas la même valeur que la
lune dans 69 oui ça nous rajeunit pas et
puis françois pour une fois qu'un
événement est positif
profitons-en maxime des gayets le côté
consensuel de thomas pesquet qui dit
qu'effectivement la planète est belle et
qu'il faut la protéger et qu la paix
dans le monde c'est bien ça vous va où
ça vous fait un peu sourire eux il n'y a
peut-être pas suffisamment d'esprit
français voit la façon d s'exprime non
mais écoutez c'est assez enfin voilà où
je vous rejoins c'est que on a
aujourd'hui
une star est donc qui prend les quelques
fois les mauvais plis des stars il est
obligé d'être consensuel illettré mais
par ailleurs il est pédagogue et
deuxièmement si c'est une star c'est
aussi parce qu'il a des qualités qui lui
sont propres c'est à dire que je ne dis
pas que c'est ça va être une star
internationale mais il ya de l'écho
aussi aux états unis et c'est quelqu'un
qui je pense peut incarner ce nouveau
moment de la conquête spatiale
et ça il faut voilà je pense que c'est
plutôt positif et objectivement il fait
moi je le vois et on voit aujourd'hui
notamment chez les jeunes générations
il permet de créer un engouement un
intérêt assez problématique là qui fait
plaisir et utile on peut pas à la fois
nous expliquer que la france se
désintéresse des matières scientifiques
etc
et puis ne pas se féliciter d'avoir des
ambassadeurs de ce type là objectivement
je pense que c'est plutôt positif mais
n'oublions pas que les vrais aventuriers
ce sont les pères de famille comme
disait charles payer un pas seulement
les gens qui voudraient pas ce fut pour
en revenir à thomas pesquet oui mais oui
mais vous savez dans ces cas là je le
fait d'avoir thomas pesquet aide
voilà en plus il faut ajouter que
j'étais un peu mauvaise langue en
critiquant le propos de thomas pesquet
parce que celui ci
de toute façon est soumis à un devoir de
réserve très strict parce que c'était un
collaborateur du service public et que
donc même s'il pense des choses un peu
plus clivante il ne le dirai pas et
c'est sans doute mieux ainsi
et nous reste quelques minutes pour
revenir un sujet plus léger et plus
proche d'eux sur la couverture du figaro
magazine de ce week end un autre spécial
chambres d'hôtes vous savez que c'est un
des numéros qu'on vend le mieux dans
l'année c'est peut être une leçon de
modestie parce que c'est pas forcément
celui qui journalistique mans et le plus
innovant puisque on le publie tous les
ans mais ça passionne le lecteur 150
adresses vous de là vers lui comme tout
ce qui est publié dans ce magazine gens
créent ça vous voyez des tendances cette
année non ce que ce qui est ce qui est
amusant c'est commencent à tomber sur
des chambres d'hôtes dont les
propriétaires disent qu'ils ont ouvert
une chambre d'hôte en voyant le figaro
magazine le social chambres d'hôtes
notamment villers-bretonneux quitte une
dans la somme qui est une région que
vous connaissez bien chez riot c'est la
ville appartient par un tiens je croise
et les problématiques
on a ouvert ça parce que
on a eu envie en lisant le film aligne
de le faire donc ça c'est ses formes il
ya un an on voit bien je crois que la
qualité de ce genre de dossier c'est
qu'il y en a vraiment vraiment pour tous
les goûts c'est à dire que vous avez
aussi bien le château de poujol par
exemple dans la lozère trail siècle vous
êtes vraiment isolé vous êtes ailleurs
dans les cévennes complètement isolé
puis à dès maintenant il ya de plus en
plus de chambres d'hôtes dans les villes
à paris à lyon à marseille à montpellier
céder petit havre de paix au milieu au
milieu de milliers des grandes villes
donc c'est ça que je trouve bien cette
diversité c'est richesse et puis encore
une fois c'est l' enthousiasme
l'investissement pas au sens pas
seulement au sens financier des gens
parce que les chambres d'hôtes c'est
aussi un contact sont des rencontres et
on trouve des personnes et beaucoup
d'anglais qui viennent en france qui
ouvre une chambre d'hôte et donc il ya
il renonce à se mélanger ces rencontres
qui sont aussi le plus des chambres
d'hôtes par rapport aux hôtels
traditionnels plus plus informelle paris
en ile de france
ça fait partie de la sélection je vais
vous en parlez vous avez dit une
tendance qui qu'aujourd'hui ça se
développe on va dire pas seulement dans
des endroits reculés magnifique
d'ailleurs en campagne ça se on en voit
on envoie des villes et puis vous savez
que l'île de france est une terre
forestière une terre agricole et
vous en avez beaucoup dans le vexin bien
évidemment et même je crois à marcoussis
qui est dans l'essonne qui est que je ne
vis que je village que je vous
recommande enfin une petite commune que
je recommande dans lequel puisque c'est
vous pourrez à la fois profiter du
maraîchage là bas
et deux
vous pourrez visiter des endroits
magnifiques qui font beaucoup
d'insertion etc en plus puisque c'est
mon ami olivier thomas qui en est maire
figurez vous que c'est l'endroit dans
lequel on va voir la plus grande ferme
solaire de france qui a été engagé donc
c'est un endroit qui consigne est à la
fois l'intérêt de l'intérêt paysager
l'intérêt du territoire et en plus qui
fait beaucoup de choses pour et bien
concilier des questions écologiques et
les questions sociales il n'y a pas de
bandes qui s'étripent dans cette partie
de l'essonne
non mais on fait la une depuis quelques
mois ayant d'abord à des choses bien la
preuve qu autre chose
écoutez je suis j'étais pas qu'un jeu
c'est aussi là où il ya le centre
national de rugby
un parcours tout aussi bien vous savez
et donc il ya des gens qui jouent au
rugby
merci beaucoup alors un dernier mot sur
les coulisses de ce dossier et ce qui
est amusant c'est qu'en fait c'est ce
sont les gens n'aillent de toute la
rédaction qui vont tester les chambres
d'hôtes parce que si si ce rendez-vous
est assez crédible mais elle a également
peur hélas un peu plus de 10 kilomètres
c'est ça ils peuvent aller parce que
c'est pour une raison professionnelle et
donc et donc qu'ils soient qu'ils
appartiennent au service politique ou au
service tourisme ou service culture ça
les passionne tous merci beaucoup à tous
les deux merci à merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis excellent week end
[Musique]